[Musique]
à quoi jouez vous à saute-mouton jamais
vu de moutons sauter comme ça à propos
de mme autant je me rappelle d'une
histoire
il y avait à la ferme un mouton que l'
oncle alfred avait donné à ses nièces
quand il était encore agneaux le mouton
bien sûr pas l' oncle alfred et le
mouton ne quittait pas delphine et
marinette
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
arrate leurs comptes annuels en allant
promener
j'ai trouvé le 6 mai le 15 mai 10 bd ira
longtemps que celle du chauffe-eau à
l'ére poids assez comme ça que vous
apprenez vos leçons
naturellement c'est encore ce mouton qui
vous empêchent de travailler la place
d'un mouton n'est pas dans une salle à
manger ou alors en retissant vous allez
me donner la peine
[Musique]
vendre et bien ce gros frisé à la
boucherie
mais tandis qu'on n'en revenaient
toujours aux moutons dans la ferme
une scène bien désolante se dérouler sur
la route il faut vous dire que le pays
était en guerre comme tous les ans aux
beaux jours
si toi moi je n'ai pas envie d'aller à
la guerre
moi non plus mais je vais alors alessia
pied avant refus d'obéissance devant
l'ennemi moi je n'ai pas d'ennemis les
condamnés est passé par les armes
tout ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que je vais passer mon sabre à travers
du corps elle refuse de mourir alors je
les condamne m
vous serez bien avancé et aux doutes
vous en aller tranquillement à la guerre
au grand galop de votre monture vous
faudra partir à pied vous arriverez
après la bataille
et alors qui sera privé de médaille
c'est juste elle si j'ai pas de médaille
je serai déjeunerait je peux faire
quelque chose pour vous j'ai un super
but mulet qui vous emmènera au coeur de
la bataille en moins de temps qu'il ne
faut pour le dire pour en service je
vous le céderait en échange de votre
cheval c'est qu'une bonne idée
[Musique]
commeinhes corps la plus belle enchère
de ma vie j'ai changé notre nul et
contre un superbe cheval doit comme le
mil et nous aimons tous et ils ne vont
pas le quart du prix du cheval à la
guerre et puis c'est un grand honneur
pour un mulet à 10h tu les entends pas
il est sur le port la grippe
pinotti ton père est échangé contre mon
cheval noir ses besoins de sa part je
suis pressé moi j'ai rendez vous avec
des soldats d'un pays voisin mais notre
mêlée même pas d'air alors je dois
mourir
nous verrez le cheval est bien plus beau
que le mulet voter nous est égal moi
aussi j'aime bien le mulet on n'avait
pas de coeur les parents toi le mouton
cube où tout est à faire
oui il a raison sinon si ce mouton
continue à m'ennuyer jeu le ton bréard
avant mais je ne veux pas que le mulet
s'en aille bien vite le soldat veut tuer
le mulet je veux bien que condamné votre
bulle et amara lui non plus ne pas vous
suivre
non on croit rêver en plus il est sourd
comment mon mulet sourds moi je trouve
ça extrêmement bien je crois que c'est
inutile d'insister mais garder mon mulet
mais j'ai un âne magnifique une bonne
idée je vais m'assurer que la met
d'accord
oh
[Musique]
j'ai une nouvelle pour toi je viens de
te céder à ce vaillant soldat
on doit jouer avoir de la peine de me
tuer vous et surtout les petites moi
aussi j'ai de la peine mais elle de voir
celle de voir pourquoi est ce votre
devoir devant nous parce qu'il faut
amener le soldat la guerre comme je
comprends pas ce serait trop long à
expliquer bravo on ne vous croit sûre
que par eux c'est une bonne bête
voilà j'ai sauvé la vie du lait il va
rester avec hell and tea party à sa
place je regrette d'avoir à le répéter
nouveaux parents n'ont pas de coeur
quand le mouton pour la dernière fois je
te prie de tête
dans ces conditions je préfère me
retirer voilà le soldat qui s'enracine à
regarder la fière allure qu'il a notre
pauvre où le dit l'otan
[Musique]
tu n'as pas honte de laisser partir à
anata places chacun pour soi en plus ton
maître a l'air d'une brute
il n'est pas plus mauvais qu'un autre et
l'autre leçon principale des fous et de
s'enivrer à la réflexion et jour je
connais dévoile déjà sion devant
l'ennemi et résultats supérieurs quel
supérieur moi voyez dans quel état je
suis si vous avez fait tomber dans une
énorme flaque de boue
je vous ordonne de livrer tout belle
disparaissez les petites
nous avons discuté avec le soldat y'a
pas à discuter si j'ai une idée il faut
absolument garder ce bon cheval noir
je pense bien mais comment sylla ne va
pas partir tu le connais il est aussi
têtu qu'une bruit il faut essayer de
donner le mouton aux soldats nous ferons
d'une pierre deux coups on se
débarrassera d'une bête et dale sommes
également insupportable ce serait
merveilleux c'est pas bientôt fini chez
mazda
excusez-nous je voulais demander l'avis
de mon mari avant de vous faire une
proposition extrêmement avantageuses
pour que vous naturellement au il faut
bien convenir que vous n'avez pas
beaucoup de chance avec vos montures à
bien réfléchir ce n'est pas surprenant
ânes mulets cheval c'est toute une même
famille et nous aurions dû y songer mais
pourquoi les seriez vous pas d'un mouton
un mouton un mouton pour charger les
mais je connaissais bien les mouton
enragé
c'est aussi un animal obéissant et qui
offre plus d'un avantage c'est en cours
de route vous avez besoin d'argent
rien n'est plus facile que de le faire
tendre nous avons justement un mouton
pourvu d'une belle poison c'est une
bonne idée
reviens moutons je te prie vous faites
là une affaire d'or finalement mon ton
site un qui va partir avec ce vaillant
soldat mois ne discute pas on sait qu'un
mouton et obéissants c'est vrai je
regrette d'être moutons mais si je n'ai
pas le droit de dire non je viens celui
d'être malheureux ça tout le monde a le
droit je suis surtout triste de quitter
les petites
je vais leur dire adieu non pas de
scènes inutiles alors qui part cette
fois ci le canard mais vous pouvez faire
est parti avec le mouton
vous plaisantez je plaisante jamais
c'est vrai alors réfléchissez un peu
pour une fois d'abord si vous embauchez
un bouton wauquiez traîneront par terre
peut être même vos genoux les gens
amoureux de riz en vous voyant passer je
m'aperçois que sans moi vous ne faites
que des bêtises alors remonté sur
bordeaux et partons pour la guerre
puisque vous y tenez bon cheval à raison
de partir avec lui au nom vous allez
accepter le mouton un soldat n'a qu'une
parole
c'est comme en régions je vais partir
avec le mouton le temps passe et la
guerre que se fit sans moi c'est par ici
combien général vous ne pourrez pas
enfourché souton je me prends pour chez
je tiendrai en laisse l'important c'est
pas cher quand on part à la guerre
en voilà une bonne affaire de fait et
maintenant cheval noir à l'écurie s'il
te plaît hassan n'y comptez pas si vous
avez pu vous flatter de faire un marché
avantageuses il est temps de revenir sur
votre erreur je suis bien décidé à ne
vous appartenir jamais et pour votre
malheureux moutons c'est comme si vous
l'aviez échangé contre du vent et le
foehn alfie comme il dit certes il resta
dans les environs le voyaient même de
temps en temps dans la cour de la ferme
mais quand à mettre la main sur lui
[Musique]
bonjour cheval noir
alors quoi de neuf par ici les petites
sont bien tristes d'avoir perdu leurs
moutons
bonjour cheval est justement son plein
de voix dans la main viennent manger
bien ma foi puisque vous me le proposait
l attention cheval la m cache une longue
derrière sordo va quoi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais la vache avait raison les petites
étaient inconsolables du départ de leurs
moutons et un jour que leurs parents
étaient sortis
[Musique]
je profite de l'absence de vos parents
pour venir vous dire bonjour
c'est gentil à vous mais nous sommes
plus tôt pourtant le plan j'aimerais
bien vous faire plaisir
s'il ne s'agissait que de rattraper
votre mouton et son cavalier
je ne serai pas en peine ils n'ont pas
dû annuler tient vite mais que comment
persuader mon maître d'abandonner votre
mouton il sera temps d'aviser quand nous
les avons rejoints
bon alors monter sur mon dos c'est lui
qui nous a donné le mouton nous avons
retrouvé le mouton j'irai prévenir votre
oncle à voile à une jeune fille dans la
maison
demandons nous si allah veut soldats je
les ai vus tout rutilant traverser la
place dans un affreux effet la petite
que tu d'armes gym ou tel aliment cheval
à la reprise et ses naseaux souffler feu
et fumée s'est arrêté devant l'auberge
elle peut pas être ton m ennuie notre
mouton
si c'est ainsi que le jeune fille voilée
militaire
[Musique]
hannah montana moutons et trois plus
grands si c'est bien votre mouton mais
mon maître l'auras ton du pourboire
allons voir mais oui c'est l'autre
mouton ou allah dieu soit loué ce que je
peux avoir quoi voit pas comment le
soldat pour connaître son jeu allez-vous
une seule méfiera il faudra quelqu'un
d'autre vraiment savoir un service si
les demoiselles aime bien les militaires
ceux ci le leur rendent bien
delphine et marinette se confirme donc
au brillant général qui leur promet
aussi tout son concours demandant
seulement un baiser comme récompense
ceux qui étaient vraiment pour rien puis
le cheval noir parti prévenir l'oncle
alfred les fillettes se cacher et le
soldat sorti de l'auberge
heureusement il était ivre mort
un cru équipe on est maintenant à la
guerre montois mon mouton à la générale
fut commandant l'armée à cheval où vous
êtes petit coin général dans l'équipe où
les bains généraux c'est juste et vous
avez là bien jeunes aussi la valeur
n'attend pas le nombre des années et
meilleur l'expriment au général à ça les
patrons comme ça vous allez à la guerre
c'est pas trop mon plaisir et vous y
allez sur un bouton fait avec ce qu'on a
ben quand vous y arrivez vous à la
guerre sera finie ce sera pour la
prochaine
vous ne voulez donc pas le général alors
[Musique]
l'important dans un général c'est le
choix comment le coup trois lapins
moutons un bout tout ça me fut rien je
serai bientôt à la retraite et
l'échangent fut fait à la satisfaction
générale
tout au moins pendant un instant car
quand le solde a voulu faire partir le
cheval est un fût d'obéissance toi aussi
mais bon je vis la légère mais pendant
ce temps le cheval noir avait mené
l'oncle alfred à la ferme c'est un
dernier laisse que j'avais à refaire ce
bouton n'ai pas le droit d'en disposer
il n'y a pas levé elle freine vous ne
retrouvez pas photo c'est un lion
toujours prêt à payer
nous avons trouvé notre mouton qu'est ce
petit garçon ce n'est pas un petit
garçon généreux du commandant l'armée à
cheval féminine d'affaires entre notre
moteur vous aviez premiers membres c
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]